well here's cruz with a chance to drive
in another run here he doesn't even have
to get a hit to do that
drilled to center tramell going back and
he makes the catch at the base of the
wall
and nellie cruz with a bullet to the gap
in right center it's an out but it's
also a run
a couple more feet this ball off the
right center field wall but i think that
wind
maybe
helped a little bit and
real nice play right there by tramell
trying to take advantage of your
aggressiveness and you say no i'm going
to wait for something i want to hit
you're the one who's in trouble right
here
driven to right field deep to the corner
haniger back he won't get there off the
wall
a couple of runs are going to score on a
buxton double
and it's three to nothing
great approach this is that little
cutter away and you can see if his head
was down perfect
he was looking to drive that ball he
stayed on that breaking ball didn't pull
off at all drives in a couple runs
almost caught up to nelson cruz running
the bases right there
ball lifted to left
retreating as bishop he'll make the
catch
everybody's gonna move up that means
buxton's at third as cruz scores and
it's a four nothing ball game he just
looks so in control he looks so
confident
looks like every time he steps in that
batter's box he's gonna make something
happen
high fly
left center and deep
tramell back he's done it again
he is absolutely locked in
this is fun to watch i mean there's no
part of the strike zone you can attack
him with there's no speed that you can
change on him that alters his approach
or his swing
and he's doing everything you can ask
him to do right now
we're lucky we get a great seat for it
there's a high drive right field and
that's going to leave the ballpark home
run kyle seeger
it's his first of the season
from arizona board here in the sixth
it's 6-1 minnesota
been on base all three times and here
you go off speed pitch
up in the zone a little curveball not
much break to it just kind of spinning
there and
kyle able to hit it over the seats
the hanging slider and now marmalejos
keep him stretched out
to tune out to marmalajos shoemaker
didn't agree with that call
see if the twins here in mid-june
armor high fly ball right field that
one's been given a good ride look it up
check it that thing was high up on the
board looks like a hit on top
that's what i thought yeah they're gonna
take a look at that yeah that's a home
run come on
so it hits off the top of the wall i
don't see a line or anything that's up
there i couldn't tell if it hit the
railing behind it once it bounced
i'm taking a listen to folks in
new york and it's a double how about
that
jamel 0 for two
hit hard deep right field tremel taking
a look
that is out of here
three-run homer
taylor turmell the mayor is making big
noise here in the sixth
back-to-back days with homers for taylor
three rbis he's got seven
shoemaker having a big beef with manny
gonzalez
i'm not sure what this is all about i
mean he's the one that hung the breaking
ball there that'll be it for him though
he could run
or morocco coming to get it not yeah i
think i think paul delay came out got
him it looked like a hanging split right
in the middle of the plate
that's actually the breaking ball just
didn't have much break to it at all
slow start for dylan at 154.
put it in play
they get the front end don't get the
back in run scores we got a one run ball
game
dylan runs well someone's able to beat
it out and pick up an rbi
nice job putting that ball in play
because it was borderline pitch
oh and now buxton's hit by a pitch
and that was a change up not a fastball
it's not and again given the
you know fans don't like it but my
goodness so he's the last guy you'd want
to
put on first base
[Music]
you know the vampires are going to
confer here and i would imagine this is
a discussion as to whether warnings
should be issued
buxton invest looking at each other
and either one of the managers is going
to get tossed right here well i don't
believe there were any warnings given
after
the hit batter in the top of this inning
and now he has been tossed and laz diaz
didn't need to do that
in my opinion scott service had turned
his back and was walking back to the
dugout and laz diaz threw him out
here's hannah
oh for four three strikeouts today
all three swinging
2-0 pitching
and a base hit
mitch haninger tying runs aboard
heading the count 2-0 cashed in
here's ty france hit by pitts single
struck out hit by a pitch
there we go two men aboard tying run go
ahead run
all right france his second hit today
and kyle seeger having a great day three
hits including a home run
two and two to see
fly ball
right field deep deep deep
there we go
kyle singer with a three-run jack in the
mariners have an eight-six lead that is
a humongous day for sager two home runs
he's been on base every time today
he's driven in four
four consecutive hits man oh man
wasn't sure he had enough of it breaking
ball middle of the plate he's a mistake
and yeah he did he had a pretty good
idea didn't he
head right on it that's barrelled up
towering fly ball just matter whether it
was going to have enough distance and it
goes right up there
that's where marmalade was but he had an
extra three feet on it and montero two
and two here to kepler
[Music]
fly ball
right left field and a catch made by
dylan mourinho game's over meredith win
it eight to six montero cool as a
cucumber sieger your offensive hero
on a huge stay at the plate and a
fabulous comeback by the mariners who
were down six nothing after five on the
road against a very good ball club and
some late offense today kyle seger what
a day a couple of home runs driving four
runs for him